hi hi we're back yeah yeah last week we
had our wrestle to kind of preview thing
from e3 go up they made everybody watch
that that actually as you could probably
imagine those are best performing
episode ever
yeah I know but yeah we're back with
Knievel we had so much fun playing that
Resident Evil 2 snippet like all I want
to do now is play the real deal yeah
it'll probably take a few minutes to get
our bearings again but you're wounded
I'm not probably I'm not doing great and
I don't remember exactly where we were
because it's been a week I took last
week off to go to Ohio to see my family
so I've been gone but I have this
Clemente Sigma fancy e and we had a
cutscene with Wesker okay that way he
threw you against the wall you got that
assault rifle clip I think I don't know
once you leave the room I sure will
remember well oh you did you do the
model tank thing I think you did I put
the model tank
oh [ __ ] should I not go through here
also someone in the comments said that
we need to go back to where the worm is
Oh for those submachine guns because
there's machine guns in there we were
like made a mistake or something but I
don't Oh God I don't actually know if I
was supposed to go in here or not
I'm gonna be I don't know is this where
I came from this might have been where I
came from maybe that's where I came from
I don't remember yes it is you came from
upstairs this might have been danger
yeah okay so you were out here okay then
you went through yeah so I want to go
back I mean that's where you want to go
but in order to get those submachine
guns you want to go oh I [ __ ] up I
don't even know remember howdy
there's in the basement do you want to
go yeah you should probably go get those
but now do you remember where that is I
could look it up I guess I think it's
the the elevator cuz when I go down this
thing here
do I ever come back or is this like
perma perma locale here I think now that
the elevators active you can come back
okay so go to machine guns or
investigate down here okay wander a
little bit and we'll get those
submachine guns Oh Lord oh my that song
that's a hunter God
well yeah reload your shotgun but you're
fine just shoot him I'm not doing great
you are I'm on caution oh my god when I
heard it I thought it was a dog I would
rather it be a dog all right I'm still
fine just time it better
I need that okay good well that takes
care of him for later oh my god sweet so
this is easy we'll go find the
submachine guns that's our first
objective then we come back here
oh I'm recognized this you were here
with Claire this is kind of near the
underwater area okay a fish tank your
old friend Nemo
I remember fishy all right so wait
you'll need to leave now
probably yeah go back up for that all
right let's go get the machine guns Sam
lot for independence way you were a
Sandlot shirt yes
independence my girlfriend boy she
dresses you well yeah she dressed she
knows yeah had him beat ham on it and
Adam had some Moore's on it yeah you're
killing these alone it's a really good
movie it did it okay good because I feel
like it's not as relative Riley gets
from is it an 80s are they growing up in
the 70s they are growing up in these
maybe a little earlier yeah I think you
could go check the map well I can only
go one way I think okay well that's not
too far so let's go through the tank
yard we're at far side Oh over here this
is all conjecture and check sure he
can't Sam lot was 1993 wow I was way off
I was two years old
[Music]
did you have your favorite of the
Sandlot guys I was placed for Halloween
two years ago you are squints his name's
Michael Michael squints palledorous
Michael squints Michael Dorris walks a
little taller that day okay so go
through and then to the right what to
the right and then that's not that's a
wall not a door oh I can't go any other
way yeah you didn't go to the right
right well you weren't paying attention
but that door doesn't open okay
you were not can i no go back am I in
one of those situations this is the only
way I can go on the far right the pink I
hope so because that's the only way yeah
I liked yeah yeah he was he was more
invisible yeah yeah you did
tom was hanging on his forehead and you
is swaying so the other I can't I can't
[ __ ] go anywhere and so I'm like
screwed maybe down there try that all
right this is quite former guy in our
product team lark product right yeah
yeah he went to the Dodgers Giants oh
lordy last year every year they do a
Sandlot game and the actors come back
and do the first pitch and everything no
way all's is tatted up now there was
this short-lived show called the black
Donnelly's about me I can't expect them
to the exact same is that smooth that
kills me I would assume
means you have a gas mask or no no I
think you get it I don't think I can be
here everything's wrong all right I
can't we [ __ ] out I feel like this is
exactly like what happened with the fire
extinguisher I can't get the thing now
because we've gone too far this game is
so mean you should have a turntable peed
on me I mean there's a lot there's a
save box in that Ellie oh no you use all
right so just straight let's just get
out of here I'm [ __ ] up
this place is awful it's just a web of
poor decisions on my part oh okay you
wait wait wait uh let's open up your
inventory I know where we are now mm-hmm
inventory go to the Clement yeah okay
investigate investigate it's blue so let
me know what else you need to know about
it that's pretty much it's in a jar it
doesn't it it's an explosive I remember
that or something like that can I can't
go this way the only way it goes down
this elevator just to be clear yeah
there's there's another Clement make
sure that we didn't get that we need
yeah you can get to it but I'm just
trying to figure out which way to go all
right well if you want me to go get that
thing I have to go get the gas masks and
then go back and this is becoming quite
a [ __ ] around this entire episode is
gonna be me going up and down this
elevator and discussing every episode
has its ups and downs this is a Down and
like us discussing sandlot all right so
let's go to this thingy
see what see what the deal is in here
all right let's find out what the deal
is in here so down
I go there is no gas masks in here I'm
screwed now you don't need the gas mask
for the good cuz there isn't one here
one I didn't tell you going to say buck
you did that
I need this first of all I'm on like
danger zone there red maybe I should
combine this green and red I do think I
need to take a heal because I'm not
doing super hot okay
I'm trying to look I'm trying every what
we did yes
spotter we go the basement down the
stairs okay yeah go toward the basement
so maybe you don't need the gas mass it
just looks bad um no I'd tried to go
down there and it said no it told me I
could not like I cannot go there so
let's go back to the elevator once we
finally get out of the basement what I
am in the basement I'm in the place go
back up the elevator
why because we're gonna upgrade the
handgun we're cuz I don't have anywhere
I can go the you were in the room I
think there's something we missed a
little mixture in the in the rooms that
we were in just a second ago cuz I can't
go anywhere else
yeah tell it's been two weeks of me
playing I like every time we take a
break this is why it takes me like years
to finish divinity is cuz like I take
like a two weeks break and then the next
time I play it takes two hours for me to
be like where am I Who am I who are you
what this every time have you seen that
it's no I don't want to hear that
content no it's one of Donald but I
don't want to know YouTube of yeah go
through there okay wherever the desk was
literally only one no there's a hole in
the wall back there you can go through
that glory hole
alright you're feeling cheeky today so
search this room okay
it's in a terrible state of disrepair
you can't go past this room I mean yeah
what's back there okay there's here
there's some [ __ ] in here there's this
this stuff and then the door back there
yes there it's the choreographer
courtyard with the ladder we went down
the ladder right now a basement yes and
I cannot do anything else as far as I'm
aware so yeah this is it
just for my so you yeah you wouldn't let
you climbed out was the gas right
it would not let me climb down just for
my sandy sake can you go down one more
time yeah thank you then listen a lot of
Fleetwood Mac I have but I like a lever
hit that lever
balls balls
I didn't consider the lever again to be
fair we got to figure this we got a
lectern the brightest on here or
something
oh oh [ __ ] Superman breath you how I
miss
[ __ ] I missed what I don't want to shoot
a man breasts me a little bit closer
yeah there you go
yeah you got him
I feel like there's a lot of them in
here I can hear them
hugging all up right zombie or go do you
think he's dead he is
oh my god [ __ ] about
gachi oh sorry
that was genuinely should I use the
thingies every load say your last
handgun round ever
yeah you're both probably fine
I think there's another one but yeah
Lord that one was fast she a fast us
you're fat
see how fast you are with these darts
and your butt turn around so I can put
them in your butt oops
I think he's dead dead I tried to dodge
this next guy your pal okay
oh yeah you're gonna flip stairs behind
him okay
oh wait no you go up these stairs okay
it might be why are they so fast yeah go
through here do you remember them being
that fast no oh [ __ ] [ __ ] get your
shotgun out get your shotgun out why
just get it out there might be hunters
come on you know I'm almost dead oh
you're back in the river
oh right well I'm above it okay so it
was the other set of stairs but at least
you dodged a zombie okay so don't try to
dodge them and go to the other stuff
sure sure
there is a hunter through the next door
though damn it unless there was the one
you kill already you don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm scared
we're the one you come up
spilling shotgun can you
oh I got it I got it I got it I got it
he's gonna correct I got it I got it I
got it I feels there dude oh please be
dead sweet that camera angle hey this is
where he picked up the doorknob back in
the day I don't Claire toward the end
all right what am i doing I don't know
just check out these doors no this is
all death I'm really close to dying I
feel like I should take health oh yeah
you can do the hell when I do it before
it I don't know I just wanted to have
detention oh my god
Oh God grenade rounds on that shelf
right there I see I think they're locked
in there though the [ __ ] do you not have
a lockpick ooh that's the stuff isn't it
yeah so combine that with Clements right
now yeah are you sure it's not like the
kind of thing where it's like if you do
it in a second you die so that okay so
now I will it's herbal
very nice
I want these but I can't get that desk
with outside no like the one who's that
oh I [ __ ] up I feel like you know a
lot I point out did we put it in the box
maybe or is just not equipped in your
inventory I don't remember seeing it in
the lockbox that is weird
all right so here
Oh
give you 18 rounds - that's nice yeah
okay um sweet
I made bullets on here mm-hmm make
another 300 those shelves make sure you
miss anything
shoot before we bounce
alright I think that's it that was worth
it okay good job
anything else no none there I don't
think unless that's cool that was the
first door I tried where did I come from
I can't remember they come from here all
right let's try it no death hope that
does solve that and then what about over
here to do this one this is a new one
turntable stop you got a turntable cue I
do but I don't have it anymore
alright well now that I have the gun
what while we're down here go back up
the other stairs in the river room
because I want to see if you can get
back to the worm where is this go down
these stairs to the bottom no you got to
do to dodge though or wait for him to
come up the stairs
fine all right where am I going these
snares close to the camera the one that
I was in before I don't know where he is
[ __ ] he's still up here yes oh no
they're here I want to see we can get
back on the elevator through here okay
as I think that's how you do that warm
room oh so I can get the doubles yeah
I'm not sure I think that elevator might
be locked
oh [ __ ] no they're underneath you you're
fine okay let me get my new enhanced
guns
so you want to use the elevator yeah I'm
assuming since it was underground you
just go to the basement okay if you're
not know you're already in the I don't
know we'll figure it out I'm on the
basement what are your options one and
two you got to try both this is a heck
of a heck of a process to try it yeah
to try to get these guns oh Lord oh god
I hate these angles they're so mean I
like it is this will be okay oh yeah
this is where you use the tank you got
this you got that there's a turntable
key behind those lasers I think or that
lever yeah
we're coming back today to use it though
cuz I don't have it as far as I'm aware
all right so that's the only thing on
this floor cuz this is a dead end
oh wait this is a door okay it's I can't
open it okay try the second floor and
then okay go back
you got it I don't I think the second
floor is just those broken balconies so
I don't I think you're right but I mean
then we don't have to think about it
anymore
damn it the fire extinguisher all over
again
they warned they warned me
that's that observation remember you got
this is the balcony okay
but can I go up and down it on on it now
yeah
like I can go down is that good you
check it out
oh what a journey we've had let's just
go back out to that to the what the
choreo I guess yeah I guess just go
through the down the elevator now this
is here in the main courtyard again yeah
isn't this the what we wanted yeah just
is it here
down there no what just down there
though I can't remember does maybe this
goes down to the was fun
oh this is the hole there's a save room
in here
this is where I back to the worm room
from here I don't know what's the door
at the end of the hallway try that it
looks a lot it's red
blinky red is never good we could do
that but I don't how complicated we got
the up
we got so close what else is around here
oh I can't do anything [ __ ] you can't go
through this gate it's a long way around
cuz that door is locked now right try
that just to double-check this now to
the left a big door I think it's locked
nope
so go uh-huh you [ __ ] we'll take that
one should I go down here no no and go
to the sewers we've come so far it
doesn't matter like that that'll just be
another dead end [ __ ] put so much
effort into this thing
ride that lift back up
we're gonna do this we are gonna play
this game we're gonna win he's gonna win
basement yes
Biff
Beth Hooper it's a Hardy Boys character
I was thinking a Biff from Back to the
Future it's weird there's so many bits
you'd think there'd be one organ very
specific Biff like who names their kid
Biff sorry Biff
it's probably like a Biff watching
if Gennaro it's the weirdest name you've
ever heard
[ __ ] Lancaster
his name was [ __ ] I was kidding I don't
know good question in like real life
ya can't say that one comes to mind
man this bass really went to [ __ ] it's a
lot easier to move around his player
alright I'm not doing this again fine by
me
we've upgraded the gun now we are done
as the old saying goes
oh man tired I am coffee crash it's
weird week because yesterday was the 4th
of July
happy 4th and everyone got the day off
of works we all went and had like a
drink and then you had to work the next
day so his own it was like a weird
Wednesday situation where it kind of
felt like a Sunday it was a weird one I
feel like they should just give you
another day two days yeah because it's
just it kind of sets everything's like
off now so you killed the hunter yes he
did know what so what's this
okay so I probably want to turn it on
okay this looks related oh there's your
door here oh yeah yeah no I've done
enough where I feel like I should just
heal up cuz it's just not worth taking
one hit and I have anxiety
sorry I have like anxiety I'm gonna die
yeah
it's across
bubbles it's the fish again is it oh
[ __ ] what happened here kind of death
ray perhaps wait is there something on
the shelf there again device controls
the bridges oil pressure the automatic
control device is out of order it must
be operated manually
there is no juice yet okay
supply oil to the ten liter tank use the
standard oil amount if the oil isn't at
the standard amount of seven liters the
device will not be activated in the
water can I get in here Fred the fish in
Australia I think they had like a thing
to maintain water so you didn't you know
drink too much water or whatever and I
think it was called like Fred the fish
and if you like you know left the faucet
on while you're brushing your teeth like
Fred was like running out of water and
stuff I'm pretty sure
it had a literation with fish so it
could've been like fawns or something
which buttons are you time with the oil
yeah you told me not to do that I know I
wanted to make sure that there was
nothing in that shelf before you
triggered well there's other doors you
want me to do the other doors down here
before I do the oil okay all right so
it's across the bridge again bit of a
puzzle a bit of a puzzle here we we got
well I see you commented on our twitch
channel right here oh yeah I was
watching teh play for tonight he's not
bad so it's got to be at seven and I
don't
I think I understand how this works this
is gonna be too much and then do I like
okay I see then I like pour it back out
or something is that what I do I just
learn here so that empties it like so if
I do this twice six correct person once
more
9 oh yeah 9 what was your plan
oh I see so now it's at 10 and then you
remove 7 is that what you do try taking
3 way now I don't think that's how it
works
so now you dump it where does it go that
you just pee it out okay so that's empty
that's good he has it's got to be at 7
right is that what they said or did they
say 10 I'm confused
- 7 yeah you want to get it to exactly 7
I just don't know how to remove fluids I
guess is my question so that's 9 yeah
press that again that just drains it
press what again the 10 this drains it
it's almost like starting over so do the
3 a bunch of times
why that's 9 do it once more I know
something that should be 12 technically
okay now do 5 I can't
it's full oh and then that empties it
again I want to read it again cuz I feel
a little confused give me one second
supply oil to the ten liter tank using
the three cylinders the standard oil
amount must be maintained if oil isn't
at the standard amount of seven the
device will not activate be careful the
device controls so like I just don't see
how to do it because you can't remove
oil right unless I'm not seeing
something press three just do three four
times again so I think you can do 12
total and then spill ten so you have two
left and then do it can I stop it from
spilling is that what you're saying now
do ten give her that all of it yeah now
hit the three again because there's only
that's not a full three in there
now try five see what you started at
like a new negative I [ __ ] see what
just happened wait sir sweet okay I see
I don't I think you I don't think we
really realize you could change the
three when it's full you can't add all
of it yeah it's another bridge there's
shells right there I don't know if you
want to waste what do you think no I
think you're better just so just leave
yeah the only way you would walk out
with more shock until this Bajaj
a lot of Dodge there's like no room to
dodge yeah you know you're in that game
will probably be negative you'll have a
net loss in other words oh yeah
Financial Times Wall Street stuff yeah
lower this and then go back to the lift
in the other room
is it mad at me
okay and then have some bullets but not
a lot so hopefully there's nothing
dangerous for the rest of the game
we're still thinking now you could try
the other doors if you want to okay
I forget where he came from
very well so there's nothing over here
it's worthless oh this is where you came
from I think it is and that's it right
so then there's the door to leave
oh wait what's that noise is that noise
what's that noise what's that noise get
a shotgun out that sounds like something
heavy yeah get your shotgun out should I
leave them no reload
like should I check out the door before
I go ah your shotgun you don't have your
chocolate equip I forgot I took a little
bit of heat there all right I took a
little bit more heat I've taken it's not
that I've taken a lot of heat here God
okay alright he's dead I thought I had
mine in the same room in the previous
room yeah
and maybe go back there and just bring
health in case
wasn't it great good about worse okay so
I came from here yeah okay
okay this is where we started this
episode one panel away yeah but you
upgraded the handgun I think so I have I
have a green and a red that I could
combine and I have a first-aid spray I
have this force first aid and then I
think I might even have one more nope
that's it just bring that don't use it
yet but if you have any shotgun shells
you can take it is a concern I am also a
little shotgun shells I like don't feel
I know what you're doing don't save yet
but yeah you brought health you're gonna
be coming back this way soon
how was Ohio it's good I saw family
haven't seen in a really long time and I
hung out with my niece she's six do you
want to hear the game we played together
sure
poison the animal how did that work so I
didn't want to play but she felt very
adamant that she these animals are bad
they're not good animals they're like
trying to take over the world and her
tactic was to poison them to death wait
animals they were like stuffed animals
kind of dodges do you know that's one of
the earliest signs was to your other
shotgun shells the ground a serial
killer hurting realizes he's gonna well
no he's not I got this what's that all
right where am I going
she like I can go left here to the
submarine or I can take a right I don't
know oh my god my fish is he alive
please go through the door I don't want
to deal with those red-eyed dudes
oh they're poisonous reload Kaka please
and equip it that will we learn yes but
I learned
let them come god bless it [ __ ] you God
okay okay okay we're doing well hurry up
zero scratches on that one oh wait go to
the sparking thing okay are the proofs
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry they're probably a
lever to turn that off the screen
hopefully that didn't hurt you too much
okay so you could take those remember in
the model tank room that had the three
things I put back in it yes so that's
our next thing okay sweet oh I took all
three I'm gonna have no spaces left
he'll have one right yeah knowing you
you'll use that first day soon enough
all right now just let's check that
other door on the way back
you got the air force are ya but I got
those like cooking Navy SEAL zoms coming
after me now yeah what's up with that
dodge these psychos no okay so am I
going into the sub or now actually I
don't know you don't have to know I'm
just wondering if there's anything in
that hallway worth getting I don't know
uh let's try it yeah because you're once
you get past these guys you're out of
learn for this side first oh that's that
was bald bald the new bold bulbs that
girl's got bold balls concentrate there
might be something in here don't think
you know that's a door I don't think you
wanna yeah don't worry about this there
no dodged those zombies for nothing with
my jaw just next one he's gonna be
harder because he's bald spots
I think voce this coffee's making me
tired it's just not what it's made to
these pretzels are making me thirsty
idiot nurse did you put horse tranq in
my coffee
I wanted to poison you I would kill you
just like those animals that I'd poison
guarantee you're nice gonna kill people
she is not she they were bad animals is
what I was told not good animals were my
guys what kasinski said back up the
elevator so through there left
nope left yeah straight milah history
your left
should I save yeah you have a lot of
pucks I think I have a shocking amount
oh oh like a downside to saving I think
we've been great what are we gonna I'm
trying to think if you'll hit another
save room on the way back to that the
tank room
there's one near there right um what do
you know about the room with the tank
model and the lasers where we're going
to put those proofs in there save room
on the way yeah well so we went really
far out of the way to get there so I
can't remember because we kept going in
the wrong place I think there was I
think you can put those proofs in the
box
well I think I should just take them
because there's nothing I need right I
got healthcare I don't even know if you
need the boat really when people in
YouTube comments are also pointing out
that contrary to what I was saying you
can combine the explosive powder with
like more than ten arrows and they'll
still take ten explosive arrows I'll
just subtract from there oh that's nice
so there's no need for you to yell at me
ever what I said not for that expressly
that's great news
yeah I think you're going back to the
lift in the back in the garage you even
did this and I thank God you saved those
things are like [ __ ] Green Beret
zombies I think they're worth dodging or
killing
I couldn't dodge them holy God
what should I do Oh killing true a lot I
don't have enough shotgun shells yeah
you do they take like three or four each
unless they take more he jumped at me I
think you should try to dodge them I
think he just wanted red before you got
a weave we going back up here so
straighter to the left
Oh his straighter his left good question
the elevator was can't afford to [ __ ]
this back down the basement so Chris is
left so the other side of the camel [ __ ]
is that right no I think I'm wrong I
really need you to like let me know very
soon straight go all the way across the
court is straight good luck well you got
Adam right now anyway
son you stupid bastard there's a chance
I'm wrong
oh right go across the for your life run
[Music]
oh he got me
oh they're fast you should let them kill
you let's wipe cuz you almost had it
yeah you just didn't we've enough after
yeah I told you a chance I was wrong
okay so I think you're going to the
other door god we [ __ ] saved I've
been so mad I'm like 40 minutes wasted
those things are so stupid as if hunters
weren't already dangerous another [ __ ]
this game and I was kidding I'm enjoying
this big jump God there is scary
run it's like one good weave and then
through the door rod don't don't don't
don't be nice that'd be funny if they
came through the door like you know what
I wouldn't put it past them
can you please reload your shotgun your
spaz 12 it looks like okay
you still have your save box as well oh
[ __ ] it's okay you're going by another
saver okay
agree I forgot about the puffs okay I
remember this area like the back of my
bottom back of my pie it's got a crack
in him I get it
[Laughter]
down here just like the beginning of
this episode full we've come full-circle
foreshadowed on purpose yeah on purpose
[Music]
wait I killed all the [ __ ] in here oh
you dodged that one dude just dodge him
again
you got it these ones toward the camera
this one yes
they're good just take that corner okay
get up there I like I like that door
that's not good noise we now down to the
first up to the first floor side
you know in the same room put your pucks
away I think the save room is the other
way and then you're gonna take a look
down in the garage the lift yeah that
balcony thing oh no you're already here
sweet okay cool okay before I do this
how many yeah you have like 13 pucks
yeah that's why I brought the putt no
nice no let's just do this first right
sure and then we'll see how we go and
use put you could sneak your hand
between the lasers you've activated the
lasers you definitely think you could
squeeze your hand in there and what is
that a leave hair yeah what do you think
or do so many savings we're getting
toward the end the episode so save now
you have third that's savings there
incredible 0% APR financing on all
Toyota Corolla my god so if you're from
upstate and you are watching this you'll
know Billy few still oh this this local
legend and this car commercials he has
these or no it's not yeah yeah he he
says famously the sal is huge he became
this like accidental local so why is
there a heartbeat they do that when it's
yup
I [ __ ] hear it it's too dark
oh my I didn't see that until he threw
up help me look
oh [ __ ] off what am i doing oh there's a
blue Arab and another green herb you
missed
no it's not worth it yeah it is can I
kill the spider
no just go back I think there are
nice I probably got poisons no we got
sweet [ __ ] I hear another spider
where's cream you should wipe ins
where's the green what it's too dark in
here maybe not
I think I got you hurt you should wipe
you should wipe and then we save it
again tried this corner again where you
got the other are you sure oh my bad
they're down the next ladder yeah you
should wipe cuz you got hurt more than
you could have yeah you should wipe go
back and get killed oh yeah my bad is it
worth getting wiped
what's your health that caution what
were you got before caution no don't
wipe never mind so I would say pick up
the blue herb [ __ ]
I'm kind of full um can I do I come back
here combine the shotgun shells quick I
don't know if you come back here
honestly you must yeah
come on knows anyways I don't think that
I should not have brought this bow gun
so you see that I think the blue orb and
combine that with can I he'll be back
here yeah I think you'll be back here so
Oh No
lotty go play you need that the [ __ ]
though you know that ain't good is it
Oh Lord what is that don't go after that
let's get that what do you go play and
get out where it just stay away from it
I don't know you say if you're fine if
you die there's no consequences
nice oh wait no what if you take that
you won't have room for you'll play but
won't I can't let's shoot the gun you
don't want to you don't have to fight
this thing don't waste any Allah what do
you want to do that no got those [ __ ]
angrily okay so I saw remember this I
know you mix the mixture with the plate
it this sounds dumb it has a chemical
mixture with the plate and you get a new
plate so you could get the plate get out
what's the mixture and then come back
for the bullet yeah so am I getting in
this water yep and you're gonna where's
the plate I have no clue for the middle
of assuming of course just don't waste
any ammo on him oh wait he's lighting it
up a little bit right there okay
so you me to get in here with him I'm
trying
do I have to dodge that [ __ ] again what
are you talking about the spiders no
okay good I saved again yes these saves
are so clutch I know oh look at that
there's [ __ ] in here shotgun shells damn
good thing we would not have seen them
get those I'm running out of room the
shotgun shells won't take extra space
okay okay okay know what
so there's even more what's it this with
this that's another shotgun shall I
think hope so
damn that's good because I still don't
think you should assume that
electrocuting so leave those cuz you're
coming back up here right
you could so now that you know where the
thing is I think you could wait until
you could lure him to one side so you
could kill him with a bunch of shotgun
oh [ __ ] I forgot about the spider get
one of those so on the way back up you
might want to get those no spiders are
way easier dodging this thing I hate
everything I'm unconscious here okay so
why don't I take like a green herb and
heal are we on the same page so now you
could grab those well if I'm not
shooting it it makes oh I see you're
saying there's that remember way back
when this went down the waterfall that's
what we've been doing the whole time
trying to get that that was like a
million years ago yeah that's what I'm
saying oh it's so gross it's like a
spiky lizard
I actually think that this is something
too
does it ever come out of water I think
so
so what's the fastest way to get to this
thing right now but like wait for him to
come toward the camera cuz I don't think
he's like a paying attention to you no
you [ __ ] he's gonna kill me
I got it okay but I'm gonna die yeah
he'll know you're good you're good go go
don't he'll wait hmm I should go okay
sure
I'd rather you'll have ammo yep nice now
get the hand go around some piece
oh wait actually first combine the
chemicals what it's very dumb what it
just so the the logic behind it if it
exists in corona it corrodes stuff
around the help of course so that's the
next key you got now alright well use a
lot of health but I feel strongly like
that you have a [ __ ] on would you did
they're not coming back down yeah so
it's crazy
curiosity try combining those maybe you
can hold more than 15 with the upgraded
handgun okay I don't think you can but
won't hurt
18 scrab all these herbs remember the
shells and the green herbs in this
should I kill the spiders or just oh
that was that thing oh I still don't I'm
not gonna prove any well so there's oh
you made a combined no combining this
yeah you'll have room like so there's
shotgun shells and green herbs and the
hit halt out there you can oh you're
right there's some won't take up space
okay yeah any more space yeah you're
right do it fast all right you can
honestly probably save again and call
that an episode ones were up there where
is it right oh I have to kill it I have
to I have to I have to I have to wait I
guess I put a baby inside of you you
alien do you yeah get the I'm working on
it
working on all their grenades anyway so
never mind
no it's fine because I have bullets oh
no it's not fine what do I do now um I
can't get rid of anything let's go back
up oh no combine the green blue you sure
yeah I could no I don't know I don't
think I'm hurt at all
wait what I could combine I can't
combine two greens I was gonna combine
these okay
because there's that other one in the
room above yeah it's not live this life
of regret what the [ __ ] is a ver grip
just kidding
okay cool um yes you are so so I got a
green Obi over here and I don't where is
a room should I save yeah you could save
them call in an episode and then pick up
here next time cuz I don't know no that
was a typewriter right though I know I
was thinking cuz isn't there other rooms
like maybe there's a is there a save
room and or what's that purple thing
[ __ ] okay what is it I don't know how to
get there too much to ask
we've got some you're you're getting to
a point where you you're not gonna come
back to any of this so oh right next
time okay am I getting close to
finishing this game um
feels close your so Claire was military
base Antarctica yeah sorry yeah you're
going back to Antarctica soon and then
that's pretty much the last stage of the
game I'd say kind of you're getting
closer
yeah close yeah maybe two more episodes
maybe three maybe I don't know you saved
I did say okay sweet we're doing great
yeah like you said we got after this I
think we're pretty much set on doing 0
HD on ps4 so no more tank controls but
it has fixed cameras yeah and then
Revelations yes you and then Revelations
2 I'll play co-op as okay so sherry is
it sure you Birkin I don't know and then
too
by that point we'll see where we're at
but yeah so I think when two comes out
we should stop whatever we're doing and
play it no matter what this way will
definitely fit revelations will be fast
so yeah we'll definitely better by
January we'll be done with those three
okay it's just a matter of maybe we'll
do Jake and Sherry's thing in six if we
have time but otherwise yeah like you
said prioritize too but anyway have a
good rest of the weekend oh brain thanks
for watching as always yeah we love that
you guys join us every weekend to play
these Resident Evil's if you guys like
this kind of stuff you can always like
and subscribe it helps GameSpot and you
can always find us on the Twitter's yeah
party yeah merry Kish find us tell us
that we missed the [ __ ] so much she
knows submachine guns yeah yeah if you
just joined us for the first time with
rebel to remake the preview then thanks
for joining us thanks for joining us
we'll have to catch up on we've played
all of the evils not yet all the numbers
minus zero which people have been
pointing out but you know what I mean we
mean that is not a number that's a one
don't ever teach math there's nothing
below one zero so much number